we have heard in the past few minutes
from the princess royal princess anne
on the death of her father the duke of
edinburgh of course heard
a little earlier from prince andrew and
prince edward and yesterday of course
prince charles
referring to prince philippa's my dear
papaw this
is what princess anne has had to say in
a statement
in the past few minutes she says you
know it's going to happen
but you are never really ready
my father has been my teacher my
supporter
and my critic but mostly it is his
example of a life
well-lived and service freely given that
i
most wanted to emulate she goes on his
ability
to treat every person as an individual
in their own right
with their own skills comes through all
the organizations with which he was
involved
i regard it as an honor and a privilege
to have been asked to follow in his
footsteps
and it has been a pleasure to have kept
him in touch with their
activities i know how much he meant to
them in the uk
across the commonwealth and in the wider
world now princess anne concludes the
statements
saying i would like to emphasize how
much the family appreciate the messages
and memories of so many people whose
lives he also
touched we will miss him but he leaves a
legacy
which can inspire us all